so for
most apologize I'm between jobs which
means I'm between PowerPoint templates
which is very new to me and extremely
scary and it also means that I'm trying
out a new CAD package
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
route of trust which is something we see
a term we see a lot as a security vendor
I've used it a lot of times just
starting a time here I have used it a
lot of times and it turns out that well
the customers don't know what we're
talking about and I think there are
multiple opinions so this is my take on
what is and what is not very to trust
again here's my CAD package so if we
start with our house which we're
building our application zone on top we
see the that the route of trust will end
up as the foundation of device security
I'm also between phones so my camera is
hopeless saw the reproduction of my
handwriting is horrible here but you can
see anyway so let's start at the top an
application on a device let's say a
phone needs to communicate securely it's
going to need some sort of verification
it's going to need some sort of
encryption it's going to need some sort
of identification well as you probably
guessed by now we're talking about a
software / hardware stack so the OS will
is in the basement and it typically
support some encrypted file store where
the OS where the app can store its
credentials certificates keys passwords
and it's going to ask us to do that and
they always typically has multiple
layers of secure stories when I try to
follow how this was done in Microsoft
it's yeah we don't have the space for
that many floors but the concept is the
same you're still leaving who's taking
care of the password you're using to
encrypt the file using to encrypt the
file with the password where are you
at some point this has to stop and the
place where it stop needs to secure and
there that's where the writ of trust
comes in so now we're talking about the
root of trust as a foundation which is
something I've seen that works when
we're talking about what I wrote of
trust this when we calling it a root
sounds a little bit weird but if we say
it's the foundation of the security then
it suddenly starts making sense because
in my world coming from DRM in the TV
business the root of trust is always in
hardware it's on the actual device
itself and we're going to have if we
have time we're going to have a look at
a couple of variants of those so what's
in this father foundation well a full
root of trust will have a root key to
protect all the keys above and again
layers of keys and it's going to have
the crypto mechanisms to do this so that
the root key itself is not exposed if
you're exposing your root key to the OS
then you don't have a proper root of
trust you're going to have some sort of
root verification key to verify all the
signatures above and you're going to
have the signature making a verification
mechanism to verify the first step and
if you're going to need a root of trust
this is the one you actually need it's
not the crypto it's a signature
verification because that allows you to
have a secure software path this is what
makes it possible for us to trust the
apps we download on iOS because apple in
there a chips have a small code starter
which verifies the first part of the
bootloader which again then verifies the
rest of the system updates all the way
to the top it's impossible should be
impossible if they don't do job
correctly to download something not
Apple approved on an iPhone and there's
a unique identity in there that cannot
be changed and it's important that most
of these keys should not be possible to
change because the user should not be
able to screw this up
so can you make a root of trust in
software the answer is yes but you need
to have a very good control of your
software you need to know very well what
you're doing and anybody who knows what
Oslo looks like the downtown also looks
like might have seen these kind of
drawings this building here which is one
block away I took this for six to forty
minutes ago standing this entire area
around this is clay so it's fairly
wobbly so what they did was they just
lay down a lot of logs basically made a
raft in the clay put the building on top
and that works for some years but this
is not the screen messing this up this
building is actually crooked and it took
me five minutes to find a building that
was crooked out here if you start
looking around at the old buildings you
will find that so software software
route of trusts are very difficult to
get correct and they will deteriorate
over time that's the more or less so if
you're going to say Oh Eddie I don't
have a rich of trust available here I
want to make one in software don't you
go buy it from somebody who knows what
they're doing and yes I have a plug for
that things to remember and some
pitfalls
somebody is managing your route of trust
and somebody needs to deploy it you
might hear people talking about virtual
routes of trusts basically I have I need
to have some secrets I need to trust I
put them basically what you do then is
you just put them onto another existing
route of trust but of course it's not a
real root of trust but it could work
clearest example of this is downloadable
Sims the telco operators don't want to
have all these seems like lying around
and the phone manufacturers don't have
the physical space for it because the
phone is now just the battery they don't
have time the space for external
circuitry so you get downloadable Sims
which
basically this is and of course do you
trust the end user I come from a world
well I need to know that where I need to
be aware that the user is end user it's
malicious but he could also be
opportunistic or most likely he's just
ignorant he doesn't know what he's doing
and in the end when it comes to
selecting a root of trust you need to
know who are you going to trust somebody
has made this somebody has put it in
place so I think I have three minutes
left okay so some a little bit about
rates of trust starting from the top
left trusted platform module this is
something that all of us has on our main
board this is the pluggable version I'm
guessing that most of these are now
embedded on the main board when you look
at what this one is for it's not for
protecting mainly proof for protecting
secrets it can do that but it's to
protect the boot sequence so that
malicious software doesn't get get in
you could have a customer root of trust
for a six an example is Apple who had
their own you will see I come from the
TV industry again and there everybody
everybody who makes security had their
own root to trust embedded into all the
ships of all the ships attenders so in
one tip from Broadcom there might be
four or five different rates of trusts
you could have a subscriber
identification module as in telephone
so we're basically all of us are now
carrying around at least two or you
acute buy one from my employer as of
yesterday or other companies who
specialized in this thing and they are
able to filter roots of trust into every
sort of device it's also important to
remember that a root of trust is it
doesn't have to be one small place it
could be multiple things so the
bootloader signature could be somewhere
else than where they're keeping their
passwords
just one word about arm tryst zone
because that's the word that comes up a
lot if a lot of people say well we have
entre zone so therefore we have a ridge
of just well not you don't have it
because of you could have it if you
embed it but you have to make it
yourself
i'm tresh so basically it just gives you
again the building blocks for a
foundation and unlikely occur and this
is mark closing words don't try to build
a reader trust yourself find one that's
already there and that's I think it's my
time thank you
[Applause]